one of the hardest things for people is
to know when enough is enough what
happens for so many people is it's
almost like they're always competing to
keep up with the Joneses right and you
can never keep up with the Joneses do
you remember this actor what's the name
Young so here's a guy who's worth 750
million dollars he lives on a hundred
dollars a month and he's very happy he
knows when enough is enough he doesn't
need six thirty million dollar homes he
doesn't need a massive yacht it's the
people who are constantly trying to show
off to pretend there's something
important to give the impression they're
more important than you they are not
people to be emulated I don't believe